[Musique]
il y avait trois mois j'ai perdu mon
goût avec dedans mon passeport incarne
une carte bancaire et 25 cents
amendements et a vécu
mais je vous rassure tout de suite ce
soir se mettent à un vrai problème c'est
qu'on voit arriver là bas bref il ya
trois mois j'ai vraiment envie membres
avec deux d'entre eux sont fait d'espoir
de l'ordre et moi aujourd'hui d'arqués
rationnaires moment grâce à la série
qu'on fait des pièces alors qu'elle veut
rouler le porte monnaie
je suis avec des gens en demandent quand
je la rends compte quand même dix ans
elle arrive en bleu un peu trop court
elle est la benjamine d'une famille de
six enfants elle vit avec ses quatre
soeurs livret a mais aussi en 2000
qu'est ce qui en ce moment sont tout le
temps que ses deux soeurs aînées en
systématiquement quitté l'école en
classe de quatrième parce que c'était un
chacune d'elles l'une après l'autre
c'est vous dire si les vingt-sept saison
tranquille face à mazères
les apprentis vous dire elle travaille
avec madame andreu nous montre les me
dit que c'est la plus jeune des
apprentis la première à lui arracher les
patrons la dernière quand je lui demande
pourquoi il a quitté l'école à ce moment
les autres revenus il était convenu dans
la neige en a c'est aussi honnête ou
étudiante déterminée de son français est
apprenti manifs pendant les cinq ans oui
la grille cio sienne nomme le système
éducatif béninois à face à l'ennemi
comme elle et moi le symbole d'un
potentiel inexploité s'envole ainsi de
canif alors on va analyser tous civils
selon trois axes hey la qualité la
bêtise
l'accès c'est le nombre d'enfants vivant
qui avec les voyous au bénin 2 99%
l aigle allé voir mais un sur quatre oui
sur quatre permis n'est pas le but
n'arrivait pas jusqu'au ciel de la
qualité on veut le réduire à trois
compétences fondamentales but à lire les
cris les combler à un niveau donné
seuls deux enfants béninois sur cinq ans
10e 11e de temps mesure de livres écrits
et contenus comme il le devrait
le ch 5 les autres la pertinence est ce
que nous formons des individus et
épanouie des citoyens responsables des
acteurs de changement
est ce que nous leur donnons les outils
dans des vols pour comprendre il hier ce
avait appelé aujourd'hui les titulaires
de l'axé la qualité la pertinence
j'ai eu le temps d'y penser développant
son corps quand entre janvier 2009 et
janvier 2010 note j'administre il n'est
pas le prix mais je m'appelle claire je
suis petite fille de paul instituteurs
je suis fille de roger professeur de
physique et de fafa qu'il ya 30 ans a
fondé cette école ça fait plus de dix
ans je travaille dans le secteur de
l'éducation plus de bison donc je me
croyais armé pour ce mouvement lent fait
rien il n'y a rien qui vous prépare à
travailler d'autres vols
rien parce que pour moi c'est une place
des fonctions raffinés or gérer une
école
votre but c'est de créer un
environnement favorable l'ex 500 enfants
qu'il ya dans votre vie scolaire mais en
même temps c'est impossible de ne pas
penser aux trois du nombre d'enfants qui
au bénin ou entre 3 et 11 ans est ce
qu'on fait pour qu'ils aient accès à ce
fait être fasciné par le biais d'une
petite fille de huit ans et se demandait
qu'on a trop construit les systèmes
vivants pour viser new line pour mon
frère ya des pistes en fait par exemple
qu'il faut mieux former un grand palais
et oubliez les vend très bien les y
retrouve en effet dû imaginer vous
n'avez 6,7 dans une classe pelle
grandeur bien matip le banc et
confortable la région
j'ai eu un sac avec toute l'écriture on
roule entre l'enseigné bonjour les
enfants sortent et la page mode ranieri
qui tire aussi simple que ça donc mieux
former les enseignants se les payer
mieux les accompagner
il ya d'autres pistes qu'on explore -
par exemple les racines de l'éducation
africaine au moins éduquées ton avant la
barrière comme owen l'école telle que
nous la connaissons aujourd'hui tous est
arrivé dans les bagages des polos elle
avait avant tout une mission
civilisatrice
on rend service aujourd'hui au contraire
nous avons la mission de sortir mon
enfant d'une forme de servait d'une
balle ou devant les former aux
compétences du 21e siècle et à toutes
les transitions qui vont devoir
affronter en mission une écologie
sociale et boussemart ya des leçons
hyper importante qu'on va apprendre de
la façon dont nous éduquer avant la
colonisation
sur la forme communiqué demain les
adultes de la communauté de
l'environnement naturel donc si sur le
fond en nous réappropriant tout ce qui
est de savoir en digérer tout d'abord à
diwan matériel comme matériel dans ce
sont des pistes mais il ya une seule
région à celui science et vie c'est
qu'ils demandent tous investir dans
l'éducation
ici financement de l'éducation par les
pouvoirs publics bailleurs les ménages
ne suffisait pas
les entreprises sans limites avait aussi
pour être aux invités vont plus
l'humanité on la charité mais devait ce
tir lourdement dans le capital humain
parce qu'en faisant cela ils
investissent dans leurs futurs employés
leurs futurs partenaires
les futurs clients et ses collaborateurs
et si en tant qu'individu avait la
responsabilité d'investir dans
l'éducation au delà de la scolarité de
vos enfants vous avez à ma disposition
trois ressources fondamentales votre foi
aux compétences et votre argent votre
voix participer à chaque fois que vous
devez au débat sur l'éducation
ça peut être dans l'assemblée générale
des parents d'élèves d'un beau dribble
ou un débat public
même sur les réseaux sociaux les
exprimer bonne foi et notre vision sur
l'éducation aux compétences
mettez vos compétences au service aux
pommes ou des secondaires je redis c'est
la coulée de boue vivre votre argent
prenez le risque de financer des projets
éducatifs ambitieux différents qui
sortent des formats rage iran devait
être lui même en visionnaire voilà que
gouverneur d'hommes et de femmes
aujourd'hui l'ex que c'est important
parce que le monde de demain celui d'abb
ont brillamment présenté aujourd'hui
tous celui que nous appelons de nos
voeux
c'est l'école d'aujourd'hui et les
bonnes aujourd'hui c'est nous devons
éclairer ce pouvoir il nous appartient à
nous tous de faire en sorte que les
générations futures les générations
futures d'énergie puisse exploiter
pleinement leur potentiel avec confiance
à 20 ans
[Applaudissements]